>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Well, good afternoon.
My name is Jason Steinhauer.
I'm a Program Specialist
at The John W Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Before we begin today's
program, please take a moment
to check your cell phones
and other electronic devices.
And please set them to silent.
Thank you.
I'll also make ou aware that this
afternoon's program is being filmed
for future placement on the
Library of Congress website as well
as our YouTube and iTunes channels.
I encourage you to
visit our website,
loc.gov/kluge to view
other lectures developed
by current and past Kluge scholars.
Today's lecture is presented by the
John W. Kluge Center at the Library
of Congress and cosponsored by
the Embassy of Sweden as part
of the 2016 European Month
of Culture celebrations.
I wish to express our thanks
to the Swedish Embassy
and the EU Delegation to the United
States for their collegiality
and collaboration this month,
and mention that in partnership
with the EU, we are featuring on
our blog all month the stories
of European scholars who
have conducted research
at the Kluge Center.
To learn more about the
European Month of Culture,
please visit their website or search
the hashtag EUMC2016 on social media
to learn about events occurring
over the remainder of the month.
The John W. Kluge Center
is a vibrant scholar center
on Capitol Hill that brings
together scholars and researchers
from around the world to
stimulate and energize one another,
to distill wisdom from the Library's
rich resources, and to interact
with policymakers and the public.
The Center offers opportunities
for senior scholars,
post-doctoral fellows, and PhD
candidates to conduct research
in the Library of Congress
collections.
We also offer free public lectures
such as this one, conferences,
symposia, and other programs.
And we administer the Kluge Prize
which recognizes lifetime
achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
For more information
about the Kluge Center,
please visit our website
loc.gov/kluge, K-L-U-G-E.
And I invite you to sign up
for our email alerts to learn
about future programs as
well as opportunities for you
to conduct your own research
here at the Library of Congress.
Today's program is titled
"Profiles in Statesmanship,
20th Century Breakthroughs,
21st Century Challenges."
It features scholar Bruce Jentleson,
who holds the Henry A.
Kissinger Chair in Foreign Policy
and International Relations here
at The John W. Kluge Center.
While at the Library, Bruce has
been working on a book project
that examines transformational
leaders of the 20th century
who made major breakthroughs
for peace and security.
In an interview on our blog I
asked Bruce why this project now?
And his response was the
following, "It's a lot easier
to name a global problem that's
been growing worse than one
which progress is being made.
There are many aspects
to meeting these
and other 21st century challenges,
but much must come top-down
from global leaders able and
willing to be transformational,
to break out of the tunnel
vision of thinking narrowly
about one's interests and
the myopia of focusing
on today but not tomorrow."
We hope that Bruce's work will
reveal what lessons may exist for us
to solve our 21st century problems.
A word about the Chair
position which Bruce holds,
the Kissinger Chair is made
possible by the generous donations
of the friends and admirers
of Dr. Henry Kissinger.
It establishes a nonpartisan
focus in the nation's capital
for discussions of key issues
in foreign affairs and acts
as a catalyst for the fresh analysis
of foreign affairs
in this global era.
One distinguished senior scholar
is appointed annually to be
in residence at the Kluge
Center, and the research may be
on any aspect of foreign policy
or international relations
involving the United States
and using the Library
of Congress collections.
Our past chair holders
have included an ambassador
who researched the evolution of
the relationship between India
and the United States, a member
of the British Diplomatic Service
who researched Pakistan's
strategic culture,
and an adjunct senior fellow at
the Council on Foreign Relations
who researched the growing
divisions between the EU, NATO,
and the Former Soviet Union.
Our 16th Kissinger Chair will arrive
later this year, and we are eager
to hear from you with nominations
for our 17th Kissinger Chair.
So please visit our website to
learn more about the program,
and note that applications
and nominations
for this position may be
submitted through November 1st.
And now to introduce Dr. Jentleson.
As mentioned, Dr. Jentleson
is the 15th holder
of the Henry A. Kissinger
Chair in Foreign Policy
and International Relations here
at the Library's Kluge Center.
Bruce is Professor of Public
Policy and Political Science
at Duke University where he
previously served as Director
of the Terry Sanford
Institute of Public Policy.
From 2009 to 2011 he
was Senior Advisor
to the U.S. State Department
Policy Planning Director.
In 2012 he served on
the Obama 2012 campaign,
National Security Advisory
steering committee.
He also served as a Senior
Foreign Policy Advisor
to Vice President Gore in his
2000 presidential campaign,
in the Clinton Administration
State Department,
and as a Foreign Policy Aide to
Senators Gore and David Durenberger.
He has served on a number
of policy commissions,
most recently the Responsibility
to Protect Working Group,
co-chaired by Former
Secretary Madeleine Albright.
And his books include
"American Foreign Policy,
the Dynamics of Choice in the 21st
Century," "The End of Arrogance,
America in the Global
Competition of Ideas," coauthored
with Steven Weber, and "With
Friends Like These, Reagan, Bush,
and Saddam, 1982 to 1990."
He has published articles in
numerous journals, academic
and policy, and for leading
sites such as Foreign Policy,
Council on Foreign
Relations, Huffington Post,
The Hill, and Washington Post.
His current book project is
"Transformational Statesmanship,
Difficult, Possible, Necessary,"
which is under contract
with W.W. Norton and is the subject
of his work here at
the Kluge Center.
So without further ado, please join
me in welcoming Bruce Jentleson.
[ Applause ]
>> Bruce Jentleson:
Thanks very much, Jason.
And thanks to the Kluge Center.
I've been here for the
full academic year.
It's been a fabulous
place to be and to work.
I particularly want to thank Jane
McAuliffe who was the Director
of the Center during my
period of application,
Bob Gallucci who was the Director
during my period of residence,
and really all my colleagues here
at the Kluge Center, both present
and those earlier in
the academic year.
I also want to acknowledge the
Wilson Center where I also worked
on this book a couple of years ago
when I was a Distinguished Scholar,
and still am affiliated as a
Non-resident Global Fellow.
And my various RAs who worked
on this [inaudible] one
of whom is here today --
so thank you very much --
in the years of doing the research.
The Kissinger Chair is
really a great honor.
And as part of this
project I actually got
to interview Dr. Kissinger
in January.
It's the first time I had
actually had a one-on-one with him,
and I had interacted with him in
groups in various times before.
In fact, there was one time
where I was invited to go
with a congressional delegation
to a conference in Germany,
and Henry Kissinger was part of
the delegation, along with a number
of congressmen and senators who were
flying out of Andrews Airforce Base.
And so it was one of these overnight
flights, and I said to my wife,
I said, "You know, normally I'd just
sort of wear like a running suit."
She said, "You can't do that.
You know, you're going with
Kissinger and these senators.
You've got to like wear, you
know, at least a sport jacket
and a tie if not a suit."
So I show up at Andrews dressed
like this, and who's greeting people
when you get on the plane but
Kissinger in a running suit, right?
You know, of course, he had
a compartment on the plane
to change into, and so when we came
back, you know, I said to Barbara,
I said, "You see, you know,
Kissinger was wearing
a running suit."
And she said, "Yeah,
he's Henry Kissinger.
You're Bruce Jentleson," right, so
you each get to dress accordingly.
And so the book, as Jason mentioned,
will be published next summer
or fall by W.W. Norton.
The working title -- everybody
knows published books it's really
up to your editor what the title is,
but this is the title
we've been using,
"Transformational Statesmanship,
Difficult, Possible, Necessary."
And it's really a book
that, as Jason said --
and I'll talk some more about it --
about breakthroughs in the
20th century for global peace
and security, broadly defined.
Not a book about perfect
achievements of peace and security.
Indeed, that would be a very short
book to write, unfortunately.
One wouldn't need a full nine
months of residence to do it.
But I realized the other day
that this book serves a
number of purposes for me.
In fact, this morning I was on a
panel at the Holocaust Museum --
I do a lot of work both as a
scholar and in my policy roles
on mass atrocities and
genocide prevention.
We had a panel with Senator Ben
Cardin and a number of other people
over at the Holocaust Museum.
And I also have been
doing a lot of work lately
in a very immediate
sense on issues in Syria.
And those can be rather
depressing subjects.
This book is a little bit
about hopeful achievements,
so I realize that I
may not ever finish it,
because it's really my mental health
therapy that keeps me thinking
about what actually may
be possible in the world.
It's interesting, so this
book actually started
with some ideas from my students.
In the early 1980s, toward the end
of a U.S. foreign policy
course I taught when I was then
on the faculty at the
University of California Davis,
I had asked the students
their thoughts on the future.
"Well, Professor Jentleson,"
one earnest young student said,
"I think the Cold War will end" --
this is the early 1980s
-- "and end peacefully."
And from another bright-eyed
one I got, "Apartheid will end
in South Africa, and South
Africa will transition
to a black-majority democracy."
My responses at the time
were along the lines of,
"It's nice to be young, naive,
and California dreaming,
but let's be realistic."
The Cold War did end, and
without a nuclear or other U.S.
/Soviet war.
Apartheid did end, and the political
transition was impressively civil.
While many factors came into play,
the extraordinary statesmanship
provided by Mikhail Gorbachev
and Nelson Mandela
were the crucial ones.
So in one of those gratifying
examples of the two-way street
of professors teaching and also
learning from students, and teaching
and research cross-fertilizing,
I got thinking
about two other questions.
Who else in the 20th century
was a profile in statesmanship,
shaping major breakthroughs
for peace?
The leaders I include in the
book were not totally successful.
Gorbachev and Mandela
were not, either.
But they were transformational,
making breakthroughs on issues
that have been marked by deep
tensions and intense conflict,
which made possible, although did
not guarantee further progress.
And secondly, what can we learn
from 20th century transformational
statesmanship for the 21st century?
A while back, in the late 1980s,
early 1990s, it sure seemed
like the world was going
in a good direction.
The Cold War ended peacefully,
dictatorships were falling
to democracies, globalization
was spreading the wealth,
history was said to be over,
world affairs becoming so harmonic
as to be downright boring.
As Jason said in our interview,
things have not exactly
worked out that way.
The end of the Cold War has
not meant the end of war.
That democratic wave has
broken up on some rocky shores.
Globalization has had
losers as well as winners,
downsides as well as upsides.
History has come roaring back
with ancient hatreds
fueled by modern venoms.
Climate change is speeding up.
Global health pandemics
are spreading.
Cyberwar and other technology-driven
emerging areas in need of rules
of the game aren't getting them.
Indeed, it is a lot easier to name
a global problem that's been growing
worse than one in which
progress has been made.
So as I thought about these
two questions and started
to develop my thinking on it,
they really bring you back to one
of those questions that's been
debated forever, you know,
does history make statesmen
or do statesmen make history?
You know, at one end of the
debate is Thomas Carlyle's heroic
conception of history that, quote,
"The history of what man has
accomplished in this world is
at bottom the history of the
great men who have worked here.
All thing that we see
standing accomplished
in the world are properly
the outer material result --
the practical realization
embodiment of thoughts that dwelt
in the great men sent
into the world."
The other end of the
debate is Herbert Spencer
who derided the universal
love of personalities,
going back well before "People"
magazine and TMZ.com to when, quote,
"Round the campfire assembled
savages telling the events
of the day's chase, and he among
them who has done some feat of skill
or agility is duly lauded."
The truth lies in between.
Carlyle is too much the romanticist,
overstating the roles of individuals
and undervaluing conducive
conditions creating opportunities
for leadership.
Spencer is too much the sociologist,
overstating societal processes
and contexts, and undervaluing
what, as many people find,
and Isaiah Berlin said, "At
crucial moments at turning points,
individuals and their decisions
and acts can determine
the course of history."
My perspective, based on experience
in the foreign policy world as well
as an international relations
professor, puts me in this history
of great leaders' middle ground.
The academic literature digs deeper
than just the latest who's up
and who's down, but too often
stays at a level of abstraction
that glosses over the
impact that leaders do have.
The talk here inside the Beltway and
among journalists can get too caught
up in personalities,
but often does focus
in on critical decision
making and strategizing.
The analytic balance is in
recognizing that history
and broad social forces
create constraints as well
as conducive conditions, shaping
the range of available choices.
But they don't determine
what choices get made.
No individual is so
extraordinary that he
or she would have transformational
impact, irrespective of the context
in which he or she
ends up operating.
But it's also not a given that just
anyone could have pulled off the
statesmanship that the
particular leader did.
It's man, woman, and
moment, fit, and timing.
And so as I've thought
about this in the book,
I think of it as a framework of what
I call the three Cs, the constraints
that limit the choices that leaders
have, the conducive conditions
that help make it possible
to make certain choices,
but ultimately really
about choices being made.
The -- Fred Greenstein, who
was a noted political scientist
at Princeton, in his worked talked
in more formal social science terms
about actor indispensability,
that the leader
in question responds significantly
differently than another leader
in the same situation would have.
And Greenstein says this is
especially true in situations
like transformational statesmanship
when, as he puts it, quote,
"The more demanding the political
act, the greater the likelihood
that it will be influenced
by personal characteristics
of the actor."
So yes, there are systemic
forces at work at many levels,
but choices that are made.
Another way of thinking about this
is in baseball moneyball terms,
right, the statistic of
wins-against-replacement,
which calculates how much one
player contributes to team victories
over alternative ones
at the same position.
And one gets into very
complicated sabermetrics on this.
So while there is no neat
diplo-ball statesmanship
against replacement leader
sabermetric, or SARL,
evidence can be marshalled to make
the same point, who the player
or statesman is makes a big
difference, and frankly,
it allows me to connect my
passion for baseball and my work
in foreign policy, which
at least two people
in the audience will
know is something I try
to do as often as possible.
So we can think about this in
the broader sense of leadership
as genus leadership,
species statesmanship.
And there is a huge
literature on this.
James MacGregor Burns, very
distinguished scholar on this,
called leadership, "One
of the most observed
and least understood
phenomena on earth."
Noted author and public intellectual
Walter Isaacson calls it an
"elusive quality."
That's not for a lack of trying.
Books abound.
Some are about political leadership,
some about business leadership,
some philosophical, some how-to.
And an Amazon search
brought up 173,164 books
for keyword leadership, 79,455
for political leadership.
Nor are there a shortage
of university-based
leadership programs.
Harvard has its Advanced
Leadership Institute.
At Duke we have our
Hard Leadership program.
The University of Virginia has
the Batten School of Leadership
and Public Policy, and many others.
In the corporate world an
estimated $14 billion has been spent
over the past two decades
on leadership development,
twice as much as before.
Yet 75% of respondents deem
their programs ineffective.
Indeed, as we know in many context,
people talk about leadership all
the time, but with the same mantra
of we need leadership,
and how do you get it?
And there's a sense of both
fascination and frustration.
Fascination in how time and again
explanations of success and failure
in such a range of
professions and pursuits hone
in on leadership as a key factor.
Frustration in how difficult it is
to find the elements of leadership
with any degree of consistency,
let alone teach and cultivate them.
My intent in this book is to tap
the fascination and at least try
to reduce the frustration.
So in working with this literature
on leadership broadly defined,
I've derived and I use in the book
a four-part analytic framework
which has the who, why,
how, what questions.
Who were these leaders
as individuals?
Why did the make the
crucial choices they did?
How did they pursue their goals?
And what was and wasn't achieved?
Let me talk a little bit about
that framework before getting
into the profiles of who
I focus on in the book.
Who were these leaders
as individuals?
Here we kind of want to get to
know them a little bit as people
without putting them on
the couch and doing sort
of a deterministic,
psychoanalytic analysis.
"A man's rootage [sic]," as
Woodrow Wilson once said,
"means more than his leafage."
But it's not about
being a born leader.
Rarely is there a statesmanship
equivalent
of Mozart the five-year-old
prodigy or LeBron James
with NBA superstar skills coming out
of high school, or a perfect person,
Nelson Mandela in his
own personal life was --
issues with his own family,
with is wives and his children.
There are, though, some
certain personal qualities
that do bear heavily
on leadership capacity.
One is what is called by some
in the literature moral capital,
which is a little different
than political capital.
It's a justness of what you stand
for, and of you as the leader
of that cause and for that purpose.
And so legitimacy is
perceived by those
to whom you would provide
the leadership.
One of the factors that goes
into this is personal courage,
the sacrifices endured,
the hardships suffered,
in many cases prison
sentences, the willingness
to take courageous stands.
As two scholars on leadership
at Harvard put it, they said,
"Transformational leadership
is not a safe path.
It is indeed a dangerous activity.
You appear dangerous to people
when you question their values,
beliefs, or habits of a lifetime.
You place yourself on the line
when you tell people what they need
to hear rather than
what they want to hear."
Gorbachev got killed
politically, some of the others
in the book got assassinated.
Charisma is an interesting quality,
which is sort of what
people always point to,
sort of the John Kennedy charisma.
But -- and again, I'll talk some
about this now, and I'm happy to go
into more detail when
we have discussion --
in some ways it's backward.
I mean, Nelson Mandela is the iconic
case of a charismatic personality.
But to jump ahead a little
bit, one of the people
in the book is Yitzhak Rabin who
hardly fit the Kennedy image,
this gruff old grandfatherly
guy who wasn't very good
at being -- giving speeches.
I was in Israel about three
weeks after his assassination,
and I wasn't surprised
by friends and colleagues
who were all broken up about this.
But when I went down to the
square where he had been killed
and I saw 16-year-olds lighting
candles and playing guitars
for this gruff old guy who didn't
have Kennedy-esque charisma,
it really affected me
even more profoundly
than my own friends and colleagues.
And so some ways charisma is a
product, and ultimately you see it,
but it's not the kind
of thing that, you know,
sort of consultants
and others look for.
We also get into some
negative qualities,
because the point here is
admiration, but not hero worship.
And the point being many
imperfect people can be very
effective statesmen.
Political skills of a variety
of kind also were important
in terms of these two profiles.
Why really gets into the
vision, why did these
and others develop their guiding
visions beyond the way the world is
to how it could be?
Being able and willing to
push beyond standard analysis
and see the need for
profound change was a key.
What was the basis for that insight?
I looked for turning
points, decisive moments
when key choices were
made, and ideas
and strategies started to develop.
A vision is really a
story, a political one.
It's akin in form and functions
to what we think of more broadly
as narratives that provide the
why for the transformation.
And while it varies
in different cases,
you'll find that it
always has three elements.
There's a normative element,
the values which the
present is violating
and the alternative future
will affirm; the symbolic,
tapping deeply-rooted
cultural beliefs and mores,
and avoiding taboos that infuse
judgments of the legitimacy
of the vision; and a cognitive
element, the key substantive points,
and the critique, and
the alternative.
How is really a question
of politics and strategy,
what Joe Nye in his
work on this quotes,
"The means to achieve the
ends in one's vision."
Robert Rotberg, who's
written a lot on leaders
in the developing world
says leaders --
transformational leaders
can't just be visionaries.
They have to be navigators.
Nan Keohane, President of Duke for
many years and a political theorist
in her own right, talks about not
just making decisions, but devising
and implementing strategies with
the right combination of incentives.
Heifetz and Lipsky at Harvard talk
about controlling the temperature,
keeping the opposition close.
And in deed, in the
stories that I tell,
when these have been violated it
also points to ways in which some
of these leaders have not
achieved the full transformations
that they've wanted.
The what did and what didn't they
achieve, to quote Machiavelli,
"There is nothing more difficult
to carry out, nor more doubtful
of success, nor more
dangerous to handle
than to initiate a
new order of things.
And here I take the
transformational balance sheet,
and sort of net assessing in
each case what was lessons
and what was and wasn't achieved.
Recall that Isaiah Berlin quote in
which he talked about individuals
that can determine the course of
history, not necessarily they do,
which comes back to the
three Cs, constraints,
conducive conditions, and choices.
Breakthroughs also have backlashes.
And here it's important to
draw the lessons, as I said,
between what was achieved
and what wasn't.
So that's the [inaudible] framework.
Quickly sort of the criteria
for choosing the cases in terms
of the research design, I
focus on 20th century cases,
which is really more
my own expertise
than prior historical periods in
a sense of what's most pertinent
for 21st century lesson drawing.
Transformational statesmanship
and the work of people
like Janet Berger Burns
[assumed spelling]
and Joe Nye is distinguished
from transactional diplomacy.
Transformational being efforts
to make major breakthroughs
in global peace and security as
distinct from diplomacy geared
to managing and resolving issues
in the normal course of events,
which is not to belittle importance
of transactional diplomacy.
It's very important on a day-to-day
basis, but it's just not my focus
in this particular book, trying
to look at those breakpoints.
Third is the impact had, not
so much the position held.
Typically when we think of
statesmanship we turn to presidents
and prime ministers, secretaries of
state, ministers of foreign affairs,
and other leaders of nation-states.
While I emphasize national
leaders, I'm also inclusive
of transformational leaders
for international institutions,
from social movements and
NGOs who did for peace
and justice what governments
were unable or unwilling to do.
This is the sense of
statesmanship less strictly in terms
of the position held than the impact
had on global peace and security.
Twentieth century breakthroughs,
21st century lessons based
on these profiles, not
so much to point at this
or that leader floating
around the 21st century world.
Indeed, if someone tried
to do that with many
of the 20th century profiles,
we would miss quite a few.
But drawing lessons
for different areas,
for overcoming the difficulties,
maximizing the possibilities,
and achieving what is necessary.
And when I think about
global peace and security,
it's a rather large subject.
To get a handle on it, I break it
down into five different dimensions,
and then I choose representative
cases for each of these areas,
by no means the claim
of being comprehensive.
Five dimensions are
major power geopolitics,
managing major power relations for
cooperation more than conflict;
building international
institutions for conflict prevention
and collective action; fostering
reconciliation of peoples
who have been looked in conflicts
rooted in historical hatreds;
advancing freedom and
protecting human rights;
and promoting sustainability,
including poverty
and equality reduction,
environmental protection,
and global public health.
As I said, I look at
representative examples.
In fact, you know, maybe
when we publish we will
develop a social media game
of who people would nominate in
their own sort of set of leaders.
But I choose at least leaders
that I think really represent
important breakthroughs.
Okay, so who are they?
I'm going to run through
them really quickly,
and then I'll say a
little bit about each ones.
Terms of major power
geopolitics, the two cases I focus
on are Henry Kissinger
and Zhou Enlai --
and I had this focus before I got
the Chair -- and the opening of --
between the United States and China
in the early 1970s,
and Mikhail Gorbachev.
For building international
institutions,
little bit on Wilson actually
in a way that I didn't expect
to be talking about Wilson,
FDR, and particularly focus
on Dag Hammarskjold, the most
effective Secretary General
in the history of the
United Nations.
And again, that was before knowing
that our Swedish colleagues
were coming.
Reconciliation of peoples, the
cases here are Nelson Mandela,
Anwar Sadat, Yitzhak Rabin, and the
Northern Ireland Women for Peace,
Betty Williams and Mairead Corrigan.
Freedom and human rights --
and I'll go through each one,
explain the basis for
choosing them --
Gandhi, the founder of
Amnesty International,
a British lawyer named
Peter Benenson, Lech Walesa,
Vaclav Havel, Aung San Suu Kyi.
And for sustainability
Gro Harlem Brundtland,
the former Prime Minister
of Norway, Al Gore
and the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change,
and the Gates Foundation.
Let me give you a little bit of an
explanation of the choice for them
and a little bit of what
I see coming out of them.
But I'm going to be very brief
in some of these remarks in order
to leave some time for
questions and discussion.
The opening to China was
really Kissinger's best.
It entailed realpolitik
strategizing,
or great power politics.
It required the face-to-face
diplomacy
that his persona so well suited.
It worked through back channels and
secret meetings as was his want.
It maneuvered the superpower
triangle in ways
that reinforced Soviet
incentives for detente.
Zhou Enlai was very
much the equal partner.
He was that extraordinary mix
of committed revolutionary,
pragmatic diplomat, and what
some would call the last mandarin
bureaucrat in the Confucian
tradition.
Had Las Vegas bookies known
about the secret Kissinger-Zhou
meetings representing two countries
that have been enemies
for 20-plus years,
that regularly demonized one
another politically and culturally,
that had burning issues like U.S.
support for Taiwan and Chinese aid
to North Vietnam, no doubt the
betting odds would have been
on breakdown.
One of the keys was making
the transactional serve
the transformational.
Compromising on issues
like Taiwan and Vietnam,
conscious of the larger strategic
stakes, recognizing that,
as Zhou put it, "Only the settlement
of fundamental questions
first can lead
to the settlement of
other questions."
And I think that's a very
significant statement that relates
to any number of issues one
can think about today, U.S.
/Russia, U.S.
/China, perhaps U.S.
/Iran, only the settlement of
fundamental questions that can lead
to the settlement of
other questions.
It's true there are other
players in this, President Nixon
and Chairman Mao were of
course also major players,
and they did get the opera.
But Kissinger and Zhou were
the statecraft strategists.
Gorbachev made the key decision
to bring the Cold War to an end.
And while he gets the
bulk of the credit,
some also goes to Ronald Reagan.
It wasn't as essentially equal
a role as Kissinger and Zhou,
so I do bring Reagan
into the analysis more
than some, less than others.
I focus the profile
principally on Gorbachev.
As bad as things were for the
Soviet Union, the Afghanistan War,
the economy, restiveness all over
Eastern Europe, it wasn't a given
that another Soviet leader
would have made the decisions
that Gorbachev did, thus
the statesmanship moneyball.
While Gorbachev acknowledges
his own leadership failures,
as he says in his memoirs, quote,
"Looking back, on can see blemishes
and mistakes that could have
been avoided," and while he ended
up eliminated from the Russian
political scene, his impact endured.
The Cold War ended.
It ended peacefully.
And Vladimir Putin notwithstanding,
today's tensions are nothing
like the competition between
nuclear arms superpowers
with global ambitions
and competing ideologies
that largely define the world scene
for the second half
of the 20th century.
So when you hear people
talking about the New Cold War,
I think what we're
seeing is a major power --
a classical major power competition
between the United
States and Russia.
But we shouldn't forget what
the Cold War was really about.
And so my argument is that
endured despite the current state
of relations.
For a while, of course, it
seemed like the great game
of major politics might
be a thing of the past.
Russian and American
leaders were embracing,
Bill Clinton and Boris Yeltsin.
Peering into each other's eyes
and getting a sense of his soul,
George W. Bush after his
first meeting with Putin.
Declaring a reset to get
relations back on track,
Barrack Obama and Dmitry Medvedev.
The interweaving of China into
the global economy was supposed
to temper its rise.
The United States claimed to be
playing its leadership role in ways
that were in the interest of the
overall international community.
But again, it hasn't
worked out that way.
Russia has been more aggressive
than at any time since the Cold War;
China has been flexing
its muscles in Asia;
and the Bush Administration went
to war in Iraq over the opposition
of much of the world;
the expectation
that greeted Barrack Obama
that all will be fine
with a more multilateralist
American President was not met
in any enduring way over the
course of his presidency.
And what comes next
in the United States?
Separate conversation [chuckle].
But as we try to get U.S.
/Russia/China relations on a better
track, there are a number of lessons
that I try to draw out from
the Kissinger/Zhou relationship
and the Gorbachev breakthrough.
Building international institutions,
when I was first thinking
about the book I really had Wilson
very much in mind for the main focus
of international institutions,
you know, making the world safe
for democracy, international
cooperation through new League
of Nations, Wilsonianism as
an enduring school of thought.
But the more I dug into the reading,
much of which I actually did
at the Wilson Center on this
part, in research about Wilson,
the more the limits of his
transformationalism became apparent.
The standard view that Americans
were just bent on retreating
into isolationism after the Great
War is actually much too knee-jerk.
When you look at actually
the politics of the moment,
Wilson could have gotten
the Versailles Treaty
and U.S. League membership ratified,
but he hugely mismanaged
the domestic politics.
And for all his high-mindedness,
the design of the League
was fundamentally flawed.
So it's the limits of Wilson's
transformational statesmanship
that's instructive and that I use
as sort of an initial mini-profile.
FDR as the principle architect
of the U.N. succeeded
where Wilson didn't.
While designing an international
institution is its own active
statesmanship, his untimely
death meant that he never got
to play a direct role in
bringing it to fruition.
Had he lived, his imprint on the
U.N. may have been even greater.
Another we'll-never-know
is whether FDR's musings
about resigning the presidency
and taking up the leadership
of the U.N. would have come to pass.
As things turned out, the first
U.N. Secretary General, Trygve Lie,
had such a difficult time in the
position that he left, calling it,
quote, "The most impossible
job in the world."
Lie's successor Dag Hammarskjold
would prove differently.
And he more than any other
leader showed how impactful an
international institution
the United Nations could be.
He made the position a genuine
leadership one, a secular pope,
as he and others called it,
and showed what the
U.N. could contribute
to building global
peace and security.
This comes through
in his overall effort
to strengthen the U.N.
institutionally,
guided by a conception of the
international public servant,
and especially in his handling
of three crises that I focus
on in the book, American/Korean War
POWs held by the People's Republic
of China in 1954, the
1956 Suez Crisis spurred
by the British/French/Israel
invasion of Egypt,
and the 1960-61 Congo Crisis.
At a time in which the world
needs a more effective U.N. --
other international
institutions as well,
but the U.N. having the most bearing
on global peace and security --
there is much to be learned
from someone who was eulogized
by U.S. Ambassador to the U.N.
Adlai Stevenson as, quote,
"A brilliant mind, a brave
and compassionate spirit.
I doubt if any living man has
done more to further the search
for a world in which men solve their
problems by peaceful means and not
by force than this
gallant friend of us all."
The final part of this chapter lays
out what I call the job description
for a 21st century
Hammarskjoldian Secretary General.
While this is not the only element
of making the U.N. more effective,
and while a more effective U.N.
is not the only international
institutional reform needed, a
more effective U.N. won't happen
without a Secretary General
with the statesmanship qualities
Hammarskjold had.
And without an effective U.N.,
other international
institutional reforms won't suffice.
So the way I'm doing this is I'm
writing a variety of offshoots.
I'm writing an article this summer
for more of a policy journal
as we go into this search for
a new U.N. Secretary General
in which there is much emphasis
on gender and geography,
and appropriately, but making the
argument about why it's really
about the job description.
And I'm going to do that with
a lot of pieces of this to sort
of get pieces out along
the way to the book.
But I think as we move
toward September
when I think this decision gets
made, there's enormous lessons
in the role that Hammarskjold
played.
Mandela, of course,
is the iconic case
of reconciliation among peoples,
leading the fight to end apartheid
through peaceful means, and the
global icon that he embodied.
The dignity with which he
endured his nearly three decades
as a political prisoner inspired
so many people around the world,
as well as in his own country.
His commitment to reconciliation
fathered the rebirth
of his own nation and presented the
world with a very different model
from those seeking
retribution and revenge.
His moral capacity to differentiate
between hatred of the system
and hatred of whites was
a statesmanship contrast
to the demagogic leaders
in so many other parts
of the world fomenting
identity-based killings.
For Sadat, who had built is
career quite conventionally
through the Egyptian military and
was generally seen as a placeholder
until a stronger successor
to Gamal Abdel Nasser rose,
it was a long and surprising
journey.
It ended with an assassin's
bullet, but before then along
with U.S. President Jimmy Carter
and Israeli Prime Minister
Menachem Begin --
who again are prat of the story,
but not the crucial focus --
he forged the first piece
of Arab/Israeli peace.
And so, too, with Rabin who had
been the top military commander
in the 1967 war that had
conquered the West Bank
and other Arab territories.
And as Defense Minister during the
1987 Palestinian Intifada allegedly
[inaudible] of breaking bones,
became the Prime Minister
who in 1993 shook hands with
PLO leader Yasser Arafat
and signed a series of peace
agreements until he, too,
was struck down by an assassin.
True, the pieces of peace
they laid were partial,
but without them there would be
even less chance of ever getting
to a full Israeli peace --
full Arab/Israeli peace.
And in the spirit of the
impact held, not just the --
impact had, not just position
held, I'm trying to bring in others
to demonstrate how in this
particular case of Northern Ireland,
Betty Williams and Mairead Corrigan
who in 1976 founded the Northern
Ireland Women of Peace at the height
of the violence of the
troubles as everyday people
who in their own ways demonstrated
transformational statesmanship.
The troubles had taken
the death toll
from about 16 in 1969
to 500 by 1972.
And while there was never only
one factor, these two women
and the organization they formed
got a great deal of credit
for the steep decline to
111 in 1977, 82 in 1978,
and never reaching
those levels again.
They inspired people
to speak up, stand up,
and turn out against the violence.
They catalyzed outrage
from the people
in whose names the violence
was being perpetrated,
yet who were paying the price,
Protestants and Catholics together
to a greater extent
than ever before.
Not a full resolution
of the conflict,
but a seminal breakthrough.
Indeed, George Mitchell,
the principle negotiator
of the 1998 Good Friday Agreement,
would later write the foreword
for a book about Corrigan
and Williams,
recognizing their contribution to
what ultimately became the agreement
that he helped negotiate.
These politics of identity,
which we were talking
about at the Holocaust
Museum this morning,
who I am versus who you are,
are even more prevalent today
than in the 20th century.
They have been much
more the continuation
than the end of history.
But history shapes,
it does not determine.
When demagogic leaders --
political leaders intentionally fuel
identity-based conflicts, hatreds
become all the more visceral,
the killing wanted and massive.
When statesmen like Sadat, Rabin,
and Mandela and everyday people
like Corrigan and Williams
provide more positive leadership,
reconciliation is possible.
And I draw lessons here for our
era's identity-based conflicts
in the Middle East,
Africa, and elsewhere.
In terms of freedom
and human rights --
and I'm going to run through this
quickly so we can have some time
to discuss -- if you think about
the 20th century freedom agenda,
there are three main elements.
One was decolonization and
independence, and here I use Gandhi
as the principle profile for
his nationalism and passivism
that not only shaped India,
but resonated globally
as the world transitioned from the
Imperial Age to Post-Colonialism.
It had democratization
both from communist rule
and Soviet imperial control.
And here there is similarities
and contrasts between Walesa
and Vaclav Havel that
are very interesting.
And also, by the way, in
the spirit of imperfections,
there are more positives about the
role of leaders of the Liberation,
and less so in terms of the
roles they played once they
became President.
And also democratization
in terms of freeing
from military [inaudible]
dictatorship.
And here I include Aung San Suu
Kyi for her courageous defiance
of the Burma military dictatorship.
And again, this is an
absolutely fascinating case,
because those of you who have
been following Burma now know
that while she's played
this extraordinary role
in bringing back democracy to
Burma, there is this huge issue
of the Rohingya Muslim minority in
Burma which is -- there are 135 --
136 minorities in Burma,
135 are recognized.
They don't have other rights,
but the Rohingya are not even
yet granted status
as state citizens,
and they've been persecuted
by the previous governments.
And so the question of what her
policy would be remains uncertain.
She is now Counselor,
quasi-President.
And so far -- I mean, just this one
example that happened the other day,
the American Ambassador to Burma
made a statement of condolence
for these Rohingya families
that had drowned at sea
on these makeshift boats, simply a
condolence, and she called him in
and told him that he really
couldn't use that word,
because they were not a
recognized state minority.
So as I write the book I'm
trying to bring out the tensions
in these breakthroughs, and again,
away from the perfect people.
And you know, I've
got four or five --
I've got a few more months to
publication to see where this goes.
And the great debate is
whether or not she is sort
of doing a walk-before-you-run,
you know,
trying to keep the military
contained and will ultimately move
to this core set of values, or
whether her advocacy of freedom
and human rights really pertain
more to political prisoners.
And the other profile is the
founder of Amnesty International,
a British lawyer named
Peter Benenson.
And I include them because Amnesty
International really launched the
contemporary human rights movement.
Benenson himself was
a bit of an odd duck.
He was actually kicked out of
Amnesty International about five
or six years after he founded it.
But I think it's very
important, and what I try to get
out here is this lead role
for social movements, NGOs,
and other unofficial groups,
which is increasingly a part
of our 21st century world that
we see even in the 20th century.
And here starting with
the Amnesty International,
which opened up the door to Human
Rights Watch, Humanity United,
all these other groups that are very
much a part, I think, of the efforts
to make transformations on human
rights in the 21st century.
Last category is sustainable
development.
It was only in the late 20th century
that sustainability finally started
to be recognized as a priority.
Gro Harlem Brundtland, who is
three-time Prime Minister of Norway,
is really included
principally for her work
in the international arena first
as Chairwoman in the early --
in the 1980s for the World
Commission on Environment
and Development, which coined
the term sustainable development.
And then as Director General of the
WHO, the World Health Organization,
1998 to 2003, in which she sort
of rescued it from a period
of corruption and inefficacy
and brought it back --
something that hasn't that -- as
much continued by her successors.
But one of the things she did was
he made health an integral component
of four of the eight United
Nations millennium development goals
that had guided policy
from 2000 to 2015
for the overall global
antipoverty agenda.
And so I talk here,
too, about the role
of another international
institution, and her particular role
and the leadership that she provided
that I think was quite unique.
On the environment -- and as Jason
said, you know, transparency here,
I for many years worked in a
variety of capacities for Senator
and Vice President Al Gore as one
of his former policy advisors.
I did not work on climate change
other than when he first started
out being, asked to hold
up these giant posters
until he got his Apple
slideshow going.
But I think that Gore represents
an interesting case both
in his political successes
and failures,
with lessons from both
to be carried forward.
And I think I try to draw
those out, where he succeeded
in making it an issue, and where he
didn't during his political career,
and then the career
that has come after.
The IPCC is also included
both for its particular work
on global environmental issues
and as an example of the role
of multilateral independent
expert commissions.
The Gates Foundation I
include for similar reasons
as the Amnesty International,
both for what it's done,
but for this broader notion of
social entrepreneurship in this area
of sustainability as
playing a crucial role.
It's also the case
that is with said back
in 2005 before our World Health
Organization meeting in Geneva,
a Swiss newspaper ran the headline,
"The health of the world depends
more on Bill Gates than on the WHO."
Though in exaggeration, it
made a point about the role
of the Gates Foundation and
more broadly about NGO's
and social entrepreneurs
and issues of global health
and other aspects of sustainability.
In his very powerful
book, Collapse ,
how societies choose
to fail or succeed.
Jared Diamond poses
the star question
about how could a society
fail to have seen the dangers
that seem so clear in retrospect?
Then he talks about
Easter Island and others.
He also says, "Globalization makes
it impossible for modern societies
to collapse in isolation."
You know, so we think about
security, we put much emphasis duly
on things like weapons of mass
destruction and a variety of things.
But I think we also live in a
world in which climate change
and these other issues,
sustainability, are not something
out in the future, but
they're very much here today.
There was an article in
the paper the other day;
it was called the "First climate
refugees in the United States."
And so I'm trying to
get at this issue
as an increasingly important issue.
So I'm going to stop there,
hopefully giving you an overview
of the book and how I'm both
using the cases and trying
to draw out the profiles.
Let me just close by going back
to John Kennedy's Profiles
in Courage .
It was about American politics,
not world affairs, U.S. Senators,
not world leaders, but in
rereading Profiles in Courage ,
I was struck by the concern
that today, that is 1956 quote,
"The challenge of political
courage ludes --
looms larger than ever before.
For our everyday life is becoming
so saturated," this is 1956,
"With a tremendous power
of mass communications.
Our political life has become
so expensive, so mechanized
and so dominated by
professional politicians
and public relations men,
that the idealists who dream
of independent statesmanship is
rudely awakened by the necessities
of election and accomplishment."
Many say that if he thought it was
hard then, he should see what it's
like in our 21st Century media
environment with the logs
and the iPhone cameras and
social media, cable TV,
multibillion dollar
political campaigns, etcetera.
Indeed there's been spade
of books telling us, quote,
"Historical greatness
in the American presidency
has gone the way of the dodo."
It is quote, "The end of power
from boardrooms to battlefields
and churches to states, that
it's the end of leadership,
that we're just sending
in the global anarchy."
There's a little bit too much woe
is us-ism for my taste in this.
The problem of bold leadership has
always been there in every era,
in every area of societal life,
in every country internationally.
Transformational statesmanship
is difficult, we've seen that,
but it's possible we've
also seen that.
If we're to meet the challenges
of the global peace, security
and justice here in the 21st
Century, it is necessary.
Standard statesmanship
just won't fill the bill;
it can't just be all transactional.
And my goal in this book is
to show what has been possible
when thought impossible in the
20th Century and to propose ideas
and strategies for our
current global agenda,
to help get from how the world
is to how it can and needs to be.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
So, Jason has a microphone
and welcome questions
and comments from anyone.
>> Let me first say that I find
it to be a very incredible,
interesting summing up
of very complex issues.
I'm not from this spot of the world,
I'm from the Caribbean, so you know,
I studied in Netherlands, America,
but I'm from the Caribbean,
so I'm just saying that
so that you understand
where I'm coming from
too [inaudible].
You know, some of the people
you are summing up here, I mean,
they are big and important people.
You talk about Al Gore
and the IPCC, I mean,
I'm wondering about Jimmy
Carter and his -- his role.
I mean, he's played
a tremendous role.
I mean, to a certain extent,
I think an even more important
than Al Gore, but be that as it may.
And what I see is that
really much more kind
of radically leaders
from the third world.
I'm talking -- I mean, this is a
huge problem, but what is happening
in Cuba now, obviously, [inaudible]
or, I mean, whatever one might think
of as undertaking of trying to
come up with a different way
to integrate the Caribbean in a much
more independent way [inaudible]
United States of America, right,
which I mean, what's happening
in Venezuela, what
happening Bolivia,
a lot of these different
places, it is run to ground.
In the Caribbean are
much more positive one,
or maybe somewhat less controversial
[inaudible] to a certain extent,
still controversial would
be the leader of Jamaica.
Now, I forgot his name, in
1980's -- what's his name?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- right, right, you know?
I was in Netherlands
there, I was a law student
at university [inaudible] those
days and I remember going to England
and everybody would
come and hug me and say,
"You guys have the spokesman
for the Third World, right."
So, I was wondering, I mean, a lot
of this takes place in kind of,
you know, liberal internationalism,
etcetera, etcetera.
But what do you see of the other
attempts by other leaders, right,
to as the world change and as the --
as the power in the world
clearly shifts away --
start to shift away from the
United States of America.
>> Bruce Jentleson: Right.
>> How do you see and potentially,
how do you see these
other leaders trying
to be transformation leaders
in this new [inaudible].
Thank you.
>> Bruce Jentleson: So, I
think your comments point
to my -- two things I said.
One is I -- I, you know, I've tried
to choose representative examples
of each type, not necessarily
comprehensive.
And secondly, the great social media
game that can come out of this.
I've given a couple talks in
these other places and, you know,
people always have their
own lists and stuff.
And, I mean, I can make
arguments about some
of the people you mentioned,
pros and cons,
you know, that sort of way.
But I think -- but the last point
is what I really want to focus on,
which in the last chapter, you
know, I talk about the shifts.
When you look at the 20th Century
and you look at breakthroughs
for global peace and security,
it tended to be very western
because of the nature
of the system in power.
I think what's interesting about
the 21st Century and I've written
on this in other places,
what I call the pluralization
of diplomacy, right.
Indeed even in my undergraduate
days at Cornell,
there was a great course called
astronomy for nonmajors taught
by a not -- a guy who wasn't
yet famous called Carl Sagan.
And so I always loved these
astronomy metaphors and if talked
about how to a certain
extent, the Cold War was a era
like [inaudible] era, you
know, [inaudible] had the earth
at the center and everything
revolved around it.
[Inaudible] the U.S. saw itself
at the center of that world,
ideologically, economically,
military.
Copernican comes along many
centuries later and says, "Actually,
every planet has its own orbit
and there's something called
the sun in the middle."
I think the 21st Century
is a Copernican world,
you have many countries
that have a sense
of what their interest
priorities and choices are.
And I think what we'll see, you
know, over the next decades is --
is more of these kind of initiatives
that broadly effect global peace
and security coming
from nonwestern leaders.
In fact, it's my hope.
But, you know, empirically
looking at the 20th Century,
it tends to tilt in that direction.
So, yeah I mean, there could be
plenty of discussions and debates
about choices and there's
some people, you know,
that I haven't included
because, you know, I'm under --
you know, it's got to
be a certain length
for my publisher and everything.
But -- but that's really where
an interesting question is.
And part of my goal in writing
the book whether it's for people
in scholarly circles or people
in book clubs, you know,
to have these kind of discussions.
Who would you put in
those categories?
>> Hi, thank you so
much for your talk.
So, I'm a history major,
so I probably have
like 20 different questions for
you, but I'll limit myself to one.
I really appreciated
that you ended talking
about climate change refugees.
And one thing I was actually,
like a couple days ago,
just reading the UNHCR sort of
stipulations for how we should
like treat climate change refugees.
But then, it makes you
wonder, so all of those NGO's,
all of these things, like the UN and
human rights council, everything --
to what extent do NGO's that
were created in the 20th Century,
now in the 21st Century, just
serve to sort of like benevolently
like sort of perpetuate the
status quo where the west is sort
of controlling things,
creating stipulations,
creating sort of our
definition for what rights are,
for what is a refugee,
what isn't a refugee,
how should they be
treated, etcetera.
And so, like I guess
with that considered,
like how is that then a
model for a more just world?
>> Bruce Jentleson: Yeah, I
think -- I think, you know,
NGO's is a large category and when
I teach my course at the university
on globalization and governance,
I try to give the students
of a couple cases of NGO's as "bad
guys" and companies as good guys
because everybody, you know, usually
assumes the opposite of them.
Just to sort of mix it up.
So, there's no question that
there's differences in NGO's.
The climate change
issue to me, you know,
when I talked about the three C's
-- conducive conditions, constraints
and choices, it is
so ripe for some --
various kinds of leadership
statesmanship.
I mean, here you have the
private sector, you know,
if you're an insurance company
and you own hotels on Miami Beach,
you know, you're actually
really beginning to think
that climate change might
be a problem, right.
So there -- there's a shift from the
classical, and that's where I try
to talk about with
[inaudible] and Gore and the IPC
from the binary zero sum, you're
either for the economic or for not.
But it hasn't gone far enough --
I mean, even the Paris Agreement,
you know, is not really keeping up
with the pace of climate change.
So -- so what I'm going
to, you know, try to say,
that you have a lot of
conditions there, you know --
you know, Pope Francis has spoken
to it now, that it's really ripe
because you have more
conducive conditions I think
in fewer constraints.
I know there are some people that
still deny that it's happening,
but that's another subject.
But I'm just talking
about things happening
and there are different issues here,
you know, if you're in Micronesia,
you know, it -- I mean,
talk about climate refugee.
So -- so, I guess I would say,
I'm not trying to glorify NGO,
I'm trying to say how they're
part of the statesmanship mix
in the 21st Century and then people
will make judgments and analysis
about where they think
their playing, you know,
[inaudible] a positive
role and we're not.
>> Thank you.
Firstly, just to say thank you so
much for your amazing insights.
I very much look forward
to reading the book.
I represent the European
Union, which is a set
of [inaudible] institutions which
was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
in 2012 in recognition of six
decades of peace on a continent
that had had two fairly nasty wars
at the first half of
the 20th Century.
That's the breakthrough.
The challenges we're
facing in the 21st Century,
I think are fairly self-evident,
we don't need to talk
about them too much.
But just be really interested
in your assessment of the role
of the likes of Jean Monnet,
Robert Schuman, Konrad Adenauer.
And you can -- the list goes on
and on and on, but some of those.
>> Bruce Jentleson: Yeah,
I actually -- I've --
I at one point had Monnet
and the whole group,
Adenauer, Schuman in the book.
And I've been wrestling with
that, actually I've done a lot
of the research on it and
I've been wrestling with it.
And I don't like to be too
newspapery, headliney, you know,
about [inaudible] refugees,
euro, etcetera.
So I'm still wrestling with
that because I do believe it,
because I tried to -- you know,
my own sense is that in --
in the 21st Century world,
regional organizations are extremely
important, African Union has
been very important [inaudible]
in Africa, [inaudible] and Asia, and
that the EU is really the -- the --
yeah, I mean, you know,
blaze the trail.
And as you said, and we Americans
don't give enough attention to,
stopping major power wars after --
over a century of them in Europe
was really a big deal, right.
Whatever else is happening
-- so you're exactly right,
I've been wrestling with that and
trying to decide whether or not
to put it back in and say
the same kind of thing.
Whatever else has happened since
then or happens in the future,
this was really a big deal.
So you -- you -- you
nailed me on that one
and I'm still mulling it
over, hearing you raise
that maybe be a reason to, you know,
try to put it back in, so yeah.
>> Thank you, sir.
Do you think that Detante,
if it would have continued,
could have had the same results
that Reagan got in the 80's,
in terms of Soviet -- the
fall of the Soviet Union?
>> Bruce Jentleson: Do
I think what, I'm sorry?
>> Do you think Detente, if it
would have continued in the 70's,
could've achieved the same results
that Reagan got in the 1980's?
>> Bruce Jentleson: I think
Detente collapsed before --
before Reagan's election, I
mean, I think Detente collapsed
because of policies on both sides
and a whole variety of things.
And I think that the, you know, on
the Soviet side and the U.S. side
and I think some ways
Detente was put together
that created expectations on both --
on both sides that more had
been worked out than before.
I think that in the Gorbachev era,
there are many who argue that,
you know, Gorbachev had no choice,
it was all about Star
Wars, etcetera.
And I go into some detail
in the book, you know,
making the case why there were
plenty of choices that he had.
They might not have
been good choices,
but he had plenty of choices.
He could've, you know, sent
the military into Poland just
like they did in Prague in
1968 and Hungary in 1956.
And there were unusual aspects,
you know, of him as a leader.
And Reagan, second term Reagan,
much to the chagrin of some
of his own hawks, you know,
developed this partnership,
you know, with Gorbachev.
And so there is some credit to be
given there even though, you know,
on the liberal side people
don't always acknowledge that.
Now there's a -- there's a,
sort of a hero worship of Reagan
on the other side says it was all
about Reagan and if we hadn't,
you know, pushed them [inaudible]
have it, so I really do focus a lot
on Gorbachev, but bring -- and
I bring de Klerk a little bit
into the story of Mandela, but he
doesn't really in my, you know,
my diplo-ball -- I make an argument
that I think other South African
leaders would have made the same
choices that de Klerk did.
And -- and that Reagan wasn't
as unique whereas Gorbachev
and Mandela were unique.
But I think Detente collapsed
for some of its own, you know,
own internal problems
and contradictions.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
By 1980, between the, you know --
you know, issues on
[inaudible] Afghanistan,
issues in the Third World where both
of us, you know, were still prepared
to look for -- for unilateral
advantages in the Third World.
Those were contradictions never
worked out by Detente, so.
>> Thank you very much
for your wonderful talk.
I wanted to ask a question
about a subset of your cases
because when I think of
statesmanship, I think of statesman
who hold the risk of the
survivability of their populations
at stake and the horrible choices
involved at -- on the cusp of war,
for example, where they
have to risk everything.
So FDR and Gorbachev, people who
rise above and take major risk
and the consequences are so
huge, are almost a case apart.
And I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about what
in your research has
come up about the --
the character of those
visionaries that allow them
to overcome that huge hump.
And when we look back at somebody
like Sir Edward Grey at the cusp
of World War I, in the July
crisis, he seemed to stall out.
And he could have been
there except for what?
What are those character traits
in your view of the people
who take the huge risks,
like the Gorbachev?
>> Bruce Jentleson: It's a
great -- it's a great question,
and I you know, in that --
it's a great question in
that who/why framework.
So I actually start with the
why part, I mean, you know,
you see this progression
of a vision.
I mean, Rabin is a good
example, right, here was somebody
who was a general and who
came to the realization
that there was no guarantee that
peace would bring Israel security,
but Israel could have -- never
have security without peace.
And he got there through
experience --
and so some of the
qualities that people have
like that Gorbachev had them too,
some others did, Mandela had it.
I mean, really, you know,
we take it for granted,
27 years political
prisoner and you come
out thinking reconciliation, right.
So there was an ability to have
a sense of society, you know,
that understood the other side
was receptive in some ways
to without totally accepting,
but receptive to the
narrative of the other side.
A little bit of a flexibility of
mind and, you know, and so the --
and sort of this -- this -- and then
this moral capital that gave them,
you know, the standing
to make the case.
And when they didn't fully succeed
on that, you know, with the --
particularly the symbolic
parts, you know,
like Gorbachev, it brings you down.
And the political skills -- and
the political skills they try
to trace earlier in their careers,
you know, some of it is, you know,
the ability to build coalitions and
certain kinds of leadership skills.
So there's no one model, but
there's a general sense, you know,
you get into some of this
literature and it's almost
like there's a template and sort
of the good news is we're not
waiting for the perfect person.
If there were really opportunities
[inaudible] issues whether it's
climate change or others, for
all sorts of pp to step forward,
you know, so I mean, actually
I'm probably going to talk
about the Pope in the last chapter,
because what he's had is
a deeply held spiritually,
but vision of commonality
in many respects, right.
And that can come from
a lot of places.
And so that's really an important
quality, but you find this
in different combinations,
you know, sort of a --
there's not a rigidity of thinking.
There's a certain receptivity
to, you know, new information
and there's an ability
to question your premises
when you see a need to
question a premises.
And those are somewhat generic,
which is the good news I think,
you know, but they're not too
general, but they're somewhat,
you know, they're not -- they're
not the LaBron James or the Mozart,
you know, you find
somebody out there and,
you know, that's the person, so.
>> Why don't we take one more.
>> Bruce Jentleson: Okay.
>> This man, gentleman
right here in the back.
>> You talk about global
peace and security,
but it seems to be your cases
are somewhat light on people
who have done the simple thing,
the most obvious thing about peace
which is stop being
an armed conflict.
Is there any reason -- am I reading
that right, is there any reason
for that, that they're not
terribly well presented?
>> Bruce Jentleson: Well, you
know, the Northern Ireland case
in some ways tries to get at
that as an example of people who,
you know -- one was a secretary
at the Guinness Brewery, right,
who were just everyday people
and they had this personal
experience with it.
And they, you know, sort of
woman in moment in that case,
they came out at a point where
Northern Ireland, you know,
had really sort of their hands up.
Some ways the human rights
community, I think to the extent
that it's been involved in that.
They're probably some peace movement
ones, John, that I could think
of that might be interesting
to include.
You know, we thought about
having sort of a appendix of lots
of other cases that might bring
in, you know, without [inaudible].
But I'd be interested
to talk with you more
about ones you might --
you might think about.
I mean, you know, you could talk
about the Nuclear Freeze Movement
of the 1980's, but -- but I don't
think it made its breakthrough,
you know?
>> But that didn't stop arm --
an armed conflict that tried to keep
them from happening, but that's a --
>> Bruce Jentleson: Right.
>> -- different issue than stopping
it, making peace in other words.
>> Bruce Jentleson: Are you thinking
of any particular cases, or --
>> No.
>> Bruce Jentleson: Okay.
We'll have to talk more.
>> Maybe it has something to
do with a category that --
>> Bruce Jentleson: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think I try to
get at the global peace --
I mean, there are many different
ways and at the beginning
of the book I say -- I say there's a
little bit, you know, that this kind
of change, it's top down, middle
out and bottom up, you know,
there's the people power,
there's the [inaudible] square
and there's the people power
that brought down Marcos
in the Philippines in the 1980's.
And all of those are important
in global change, I'm just trying
to focus on the particular
role of leaders
without saying it's the
be all and the end all.
And some of our political
science colleagues, of course,
want me to get a larger
end and build a model
and do the regression analysis,
but neither you nor I
go there in that, so.
>> I think we'll stop there, so
please join me in thanking Bruce.
>> Bruce Jentleson:
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at Library of Congress.gov.